on retrouve marc bédard président et
fondateur de la compagnie électrique
lyon bonsoir monsieur bédard oui bonsoir
madame ses interviews bon évidemment
lyon était déjà connue entre autres pour
six autobus scolaire électrique il ya eu
des ententes avec la saq l'an passé et
là qu'est ce que ça représente cette
commande pour vous pour la croissance de
votre entreprise une très très belle
annonce ans et 50 camions avec les cn
les siennes et un important joueur avec
beaucoup de rigueur très reconnu dans le
monde du transport donc pour nous on
pense que ça peut avoir un effet
d'entraînement c'est important au niveau
d'électrification est ce que vous êtes
en pourparlers avec d'autres acheteurs
potentiels pour ce même type de camion
parce qu'évidemment et lcn mais ça peut
ça va être utilisée par plusieurs autres
entreprises beaucoup beaucoup
d'entreprises en fait on a déjà des
camions d'autres types là qu'on appelle
des camions porteurs des lions 6
exercices des classes 8 et celui là mais
c'est un lion huit tracteurs est tout à
fait en fait il s'en vend des milliers
de véhicules comme ça par année sur les
routes en amérique du nord donc et un
énorme potentiel dans toute l'amérique
du nord
on a l'impression mais c'est évident que
les choses vont vite pour lyon vous avez
fait vos débuts en 2010 a fait à peine
dix ans vous avez vendu en 2005
ensuite les ambulances les camions
urbain vos défis en france et quoi fait
jamais assez vite qu'on aimerait que sa
ligne encore un peu plus vite mais l'on
voit un grand intérêt au niveau de
l'électrification
ça nous prend des commandes comme celle
qu'elle cm vient d'annoncer aujourd'hui
pour convaincre les gens justement que
l'électrification c'est dès maintenant
donc plusieurs modèles de véhicules qui
sont déjà disponibles la technologie est
là donc c'est important d'y arriver donc
au niveau technologique
les défis sont plutôt derrière derrière
nous maintenant c'est une acceptation
par les opérateurs qui sont habitués
évidemment d'opérer des camions au
diesel et qui maintenant le seul instant
t par des camions électriques c'est
probablement plus cher aussi à l'achat
un véhicule électrique
monsieur bédard vous corrigerez si je me
trompe mais
de quelle manière vous devez faire des
efforts pour convaincre les entreprises
d'adopter votre technologie
c'est exactement ce que vous venez dire
c'est que le coût à l'achat est
supérieur au coût à l'achat de camions
au diesel
par contre d'un autre côté on récupère
rapidement le coût à l'achat de surplus
de quoi un achat par la réduction des
frais d'opération donc beaucoup moins de
frais d'énergie beaucoup moins de frais
d'entretien donc selon l'utilisation du
camion il ya des types d'utilisation
comme exemple le camion de collecte de
déchets aussi environ 5 à 6 ans sans
aucune aide gouvernementale où il ya un
retour sur investissement qui se fait
donc le seul le seul enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est le surcoût à l'achat mais quand on
regarde le coût de propriété du véhicule
sur toute la durée de vie bah c'est
possible dans presque tous les cas vous
parliez à l'instant de camions de
collecte de déchets vous en avez vendu
récemment la aux etats-unis le marché
américain a fait ça va vite c'est aussi
et vous dit au début de l'entrevue c'est
la vie ça va très vite
le camion de collecte de déchets de 7
ans c'est un très bel exemple pendant le
type de camion que le cn vient d'acheter
aussi c'est un camion qui est très
populaire aux états unis donc le marché
américain pour nous vous savez c'est
notre plus gros marché jusqu'à
maintenant et c'est principalement la
californie mais l'on voit beaucoup
d'autres sites qui sont entrés le
d'emboîter le pas donc on souhaite
également que le québec est déjà un
allié important pour nous là est
beaucoup plus loin le dans son plan
d'électrification qui devrait être
annoncé dans les prochains mois
puisqu'on parle du marché américain
monsieur bédard on croit comprendre
qu'il y avait des démarches avec amazon
qui veut électrifier sa flotte de
véhicules a fait on a des démarches avec
à peu près tous les bureaux les grosses
toutes les grosses flotte américaine en
ce moment alors il ya des morts des
contrôles devraient qui devrait signer
effectivement mais les grandes flottes
auxquels fait penser monde et on est en
négociation que ces flottements ce
moment avec toute cette demande
monsieur bédard est ce que vous
approchez de la capacité limite de votre
usine à saint-girons parce que vous
songez
j'ai eu à construire des usines ailleurs
on songe à construire des usines
ailleurs de nos côtés ont
malheureusement on n'est pas rendus on
accorde à la limite de la capacité de
l'usiné saint girons vous savez on peut
faire 2500 véhicules par année à notre
usine de saint jérôme donc eu pas mal de
places le pouvait pour la croissance ça
va ça va prendre plusieurs annonces à 50
véhicules pour arriver là mais déjà
effectivement on a des plans pour
commencer à regarder d'autres usines on
pense que quand le marché va éclater ça
va aller plutôt plutôt rapidement bon
avec des annonces comme celle
d'aujourd'hui évidemment ça va faire
rouler votre usine plus rapidement si
vous voulez est-ce que ça a été
difficile de maintenir la main d'oeuvre
de recruter entre autres avec le
contexte la pandémie chez l'humain vous
savez nous pendant quelques semaines ont
été fermés également comme la majorité
des entreprises
donc on a souffert les employés on se
fait aussi par contre c'est là qu'on
voit là où l'entraidé est importante et
les gens sont venus ou au travail
et puis il ya eu une harmonie je pense
50 meilleurs qu'avant donc pas facile de
recruter les gens par contre le taux de
rétention est très très bon et le type
de véhicule quand on fait également je
pense qu'elle est les gens dans les
lignes de production l'om le produit
reste excitant je pense que les gens
rentrent au travail qui ont ce qu'est ce
qu'on parle de la pandémie ce que vous
avez eu comme plusieurs autres
manufacturiers des difficultés pour
l'approvisionnement vous avez beaucoup
de fournisseurs et de sous traitants
québécois entre autres plusieurs au
niveau du québec mais plusieurs
dans le reste du canada au niveau
américain et dans le reste du monde
aussi donc tout à fait comme vous venez
de le dire le des gros enjeux donc notre
stratégie nous saleh était de 2 plutôt
que dans un mode d'approvisionnement
just in time
ça a été plutôt qu'il ya des
approvisionnements un grand nombre qui
se font dès que lire les composantes
sont disponibles réduire qu'on en manque
pas donc il ya quand même beaucoup
d'inventeurs mais c'est correct dans des
périodes comme la pandémie le convoi que
c'était bénéfique d'adopter une approche
la com comme ça ouais d'autant plus que
dans les prochains mois on sait que des
plans de relance de l'économie qui
auront des volets verts
peut-être vous aider un peu je vous
souhaite bonne chance pour la suite
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là monsieur
bédard merci à vous